intensas lluvias en la provincia de
cajamarca en perú que provocaron el
desbordamiento de ríos y de carreteras
algo por lo que algunos residentes
culpan a los dirigentes locales a
lluvias de alta intensidad y nos ha
sorprendido y atraídos desmontes ha
colapsado acá la alcantarillas
principales que tenemos y ha salido
sobre sobre la calle a estas cuadras de
cintio que nos ha inundado a todos los
cuadros se ha desbordado la cada vez que
los gobernantes del alcalde no limpia
imagines y cosa que la parte baja todito
nos inundamos acá nos inundábamos tiene
que ser algo algo los gobernantes de acá
de baños del inca de cajamarca que se y
ojo que estamos inundados la temporada
de lluvias acaba de comenzar en perú
ligada al fenómeno de la niña un suceso
natural que hace que el agua del
pacífico oriental esté más fría de lo
normal y que provoca inundaciones por el
aumento de la intensidad de las lluvias
pero también sequías por el retraso de
la temporada de lluvias en función de la
zona en el caso de perú el incremento de
las lluvias es el escenario más habitual
sólo durante el fin de semana los
aguaceros dejaron decenas de casas
inundadas y en riesgo de colapso en la
ciudad de baños del inca según las
autoridades locales una situación que
podría extenderse hasta abril por la
temporada de precipitaciones